[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen guten Abend und
herzlich willkommen für den Sport im
Studio Norbert Lehmann
schauen wir auf die wichtigsten Themen
heute
die Basis wird entscheiden in der CDU
sollen erstmals die Mitglieder über den
Vorsitz abstimmen
Streit um den impfbooster die
Kassenärzte verlangen klare Regeln statt
immer neue Empfehlungen aus der Politik
und Maßnahmen gegen die Erderwärmung die
Klimakonferenz will schädliches Methan
reduzieren und Waldflächen retten
wer traut sich als erster offiziell
seinen Hut in den Ring zu werfen für den
cdu-parteivorsitz ab diesem Samstag
können Bewerber nominiert werden und der
Machtkampf ist längst im vollem Gange
der Mitglieder entscheiden dann wer es
wird das erste Mal in der Geschichte der
CDU die Parteiführung hat heute
festgelegt wie das alles konkret
ablaufen soll Karl Hinterleitner
es geht um seine Nachfolge wer wird nach
Armin Laschet die CDU führen noch nie
hat man dafür die Basis befragt heute
wurde ein Weg gesucht sie entscheiden zu
lassen das Problem dabei die
mitgliederbeteiligung soll einerseits
möglichst umfassend sein aber
andererseits schnell gehen wir haben
jetzt einen Kompromiss gefunden in dem
die Mitglieder breit beteiligt werden
aber wir trotzdem zum Beginn des neuen
Jahres so neu aufgestellt sind dass wir
dann mit Zuversicht in die
Landtagswahlen im Saarland in
Schleswig-Holstein und in
Nordrhein-Westfalen im Mai gehen können
denn besonders die CDU
Ministerpräsidenten wollten für ihre
Wahlkämpfe möglichst bald klare
Verhältnisse und hatten aufs Tempo
gedrückt mein Anliegen ist dass wir
schnell zu Entscheidungen kommen damit
schnell Klarheit da ist die CDU ist
nicht für Selbstbeschäftigung gegründet
worden sondern dafür sich um die
Anliegen der Menschen zu kümmern
am Ende geht es wahrscheinlich um fünf
Kandidaten alle männlich alle aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen Norbert Röttgen als
Mann der Mitte Fraktionschef Ralf
Brinkhaus Carsten Linnemann vom
Wirtschaftsflügel sowie Friedrich Merz
und Jens Spahn Bewerber die für einen
erfolgreichen Nachfolgeprozess
kooperieren müsste es setzt aber auch
voraus dass nicht fünf Kandidaten am
Ende antreten denn dann wird es mit
Stichwahlen und so weiter einfach
schwierig und deswegen erwarte ich
einfach von denjenigen die sich jetzt
zur Wahl stellen dass sie auch mal
überlegen ob sie nicht besser aufgehoben
sind in einem Team im Laufe des
Dezembers sollen die Mitglieder
entscheiden Ende Januar wählt dann ein
Parteitag den neuen CDU-Chef
Ende Januar wird also erst feststehen
wer neuer Parteichef wird das sind ja
noch fast drei Monate Theo call in
Berlin was bedeutet das für den viel
beschworenen Aufbruch der CDU nun es
dürfte ein kleiner Vorgeschmack sein für
das was da noch kommt für den mühsamen
Weg den die CDU jetzt vor sich hat der
Wahlgang dauert ja unter anderem deshalb
so lange weil man mit mehreren Bewerbern
rechnen muss und dass keiner im ersten
Wahlgang eine absolute Mehrheit bekommt
und dann eine Stichwahl nötig werden
dürfte das ist alles auch ein
Spiegelbild dafür dass es keinen alles
überragenden Kandidaten gibt und dass
die bisher genannten Aspiranten sehr
unterschiedliche Vorstellungen vom
künftigen richtigen Kurs der CDU haben
das ist eine Kluft die Angela Merkel ja
lange überdeckt hat die aber jetzt offen
liegt und die die Partei noch lange
beschäftigen dürfte für die Wahlkämpfer
in den anstehenden Landtagswahlen sind
das lange Partei Suchverfahren und die
Richtungslosigkeit natürlich eine
zusätzliche Belastung schon im März und
Mai stehen ja drei wichtige
Landtagswahlen an sollte die CDU dort
Regierungen verlieren dann dürfte sich
die Krise der Parteien nochmal
verschärfen danke für diese Einordnung
Theo
zu unserem nächsten großen Thema der
corona-lage in Deutschland schauen wir
erst einmal auf die aktuellen Zahlen das
Robert-Koch-Institut meldet innerhalb
eines Tages
10.813 Neuinfektionen das sind 340 mehr
als vor einer Woche die sieben Tage
Inzidenz sinkt leicht auf
153,7 wegen des gestrigen Feiertags in
einigen Bundesländern könnten allerdings
auch weniger Infektionen an das RKI
gemeldet worden sein
angesichts der steigenden Zahlen will
Sachsen die zwei g-regel also geimpft
oder genesen für die Gastronomie
Veranstaltungen im Innenbereich und
Großveranstaltungen wie Fußballspiele
einführen die endgültige Entscheidung
liegt am Freitag beim Kabinett ab Montag
soll die zwei geregel dann gelten die
corona-kurve in Deutschland wieder nach
unten bringen dabei soll auch die
Auffrischungsimpfung helfen und die
funktioniert so Zellen können sich an
die frühere Impfung erinnern auf einer
erneute Dosis reagiert der Körper nun
schneller und stärker der boostereffekt
also folgt man den Empfehlungen der
Ständigen Impfkommission sollten 15
Millionen besonders gefährdete Menschen
diesen auffrischungspeaks noch bis Ende
des Jahres bekommen Elisabeth Schmidt
mit den weiteren Details
in dieser Hausarztpraxis in Braunschweig
hat das Telefon nicht mehr auf zu
klingeln ziemlich genau seit dem
Gesundheitsminister Spahn eine
corona-booster-impfung für alle
empfohlen hat Ergebnis viele Patienten
sind verunsichert das Praxisteam muss
mühsam beraten das wird sehr oft
übersehen was unsere MitarbeiterInnen
die medizinischen Fachangestellten
leisten die bekommen ja regelmäßig die
Erwartungshaltung der Patientinnen
Patienten ab die von der Politik
geschürt wird ohne sich fachpolitisch
versichert zu haben ob das überhaupt so
schnell umsetzbar ist so kann es nicht
weitergehen kritisieren Ärztevertreter
heute auch in Berlin die Politik
übergehe das zuständige Expertengremium
die Ständige Impfkommission permanent
mit immer neuen Vorstößen was schwierig
ist wenn die Ständige Impfkommission
haben die Macht eine Empfehlung die
Ärzteschaft stellt sich da geschlossen
hinter und Politik gibt dann so
Empfehlungen aus bauchevidenz die STIKO
empfiehlt Booster Impfungen für Menschen
über 70 Jahre sechs Monate nach der
vollständigen Immunisierung für alle die
mit dem Impfstoff von Johnson & Johnson
geimpft wurden für vulnerable Gruppen
etwa in Altenheimen für medizinisches
oder Pflegepersonal einen Booster für
alle lehnt die STIKO derzeit ab
diejenigen die
grundimmunisiert sind und die sonst
gesund sind und den in dem mittleren
Alter sich befinden die können
tatsächlich davon ausgehen dass sie
jetzt noch ausreichenden Schutz von
ihrer Grundimmunisierung für schwere
Erkrankung haben oberstes Ziel sei jetzt
erst einmal die besonders gefährdeten
Menschen zu schützen
wenn wir hier nach Risiko nutzen gehen
und vor allen Dingen auch danach die
Ressourcen an den Punkten einzusetzen wo
sie eben am meisten benötigt werden dann
ist das ganz klar so dass die älteren
Menschen über 70 am meisten von dieser
Auffrischimpfung profitieren während
Politik und Wissenschaft über die
boosterimpfung streiten klingen die
Forderungen vieler Hausärzte fast
bescheiden sorgt dafür dass der
Impfstoff schneller geliefert wird so Dr
Schneider Rathert das dauerte zur Zeit
nämlich zwei volle Wochen
in Israel haben viele Menschen längst
eine Auffrischungsimpfung bekommen schon
seit gut drei Monaten kann man sich dort
eine booster-impfung mit biontech holen
inzwischen möglich für alle ab 12 Jahren
einzige Voraussetzung zwischen der
letzten corona-impfung und dem Boostern
müssen mindestens fünf Monate liegen
welchen zusätzlichen Schutz die
Auffrischungsimpfung bietet haben
forschende untersucht Michael Beverungen
berichtet
die boosterimpfung in Israel hat man
nicht lange darüber diskutiert von den
gut neun Millionen Israelis haben knapp
vier in den letzten drei Monaten dieses
Angebot genutzt das sind zwei Drittel
aller geimpften in allen Altersklassen
die meisten mussten nicht groß überzeugt
werden
es ist wichtig dass wir gesund bleiben
und genug Antikörper gegen Corona haben
damit wir rausgehen und die Familie
treffen können
alle meine Freunde haben sich impfen
lassen keiner hatte Nebenwirkungen
außerdem hat die amerikanische Behörde
ihr Okay gegeben da habe ich mich auch
entschlossen und so gelang erstaunliches
Israel überstand eine massive deltawelle
mit Inzidenzen über 700 ohne Lockdown
das öffentliche Leben lief fast
unverändert weiter krank wurden vor
allem die ungeimpften an den
Beatmungsgeräten machten sie 90 Prozent
aus umgekehrt erhöhte die dritte Impfung
den Schutz im Vergleich zur zweiten um
über 90 Prozent und die Zahl der
Antikörper zum Teil auf das 50-fache
die Immunität der Menschen ist viel
stärker nach der dritten Dosis wir haben
die hospitalisierungsrate überprüft die
schweren Fälle und die tragischen
Todesfälle in Verbindung mit dem
Coronavirus in allen Bereichen war der
Schutz bei der dritten Dosis weit größer
als 5 Monate nach der zweiten
mit dem grünen Pass will muss sich daher
spätestens sechs Monate nach der
Zweitimpfung ein drittes Mal impfen
lassen eine zweijährige geimpft oder
genesen gibt es aber nicht in Israel mit
einem aktuellen corona-test kommt man
genauso überall rein und so leistet sich
Israel seit gestern das Land zu öffnen
zum ersten Mal seit Beginn der Pandemie
dürfen Touristen aus der ganzen Welt
wieder einreisen auch für sie gilt aber
liegt die zweite Impfung länger als
sechs Monate zurück müssen auch nicht
Israelis einen dritten Booster
nachweisen
sie interessieren sich für Zahlen und
Grafiken zur Verbreitung des Coronavirus
hier in Deutschland aber auch
international dann schauen Sie in unsere
ZDF heute App da haben wir
beispielsweise einen corona-tracker für
sie der zeigt wie sich die Inzidenzen in
den einzelnen Landkreisen entwickelt
und jetzt zwei Meldungen bei denen es um
viel Geld geht die rund 21 Millionen
Rentnerinnen und Rentner in Deutschland
können sich auf eine deutliche Erhöhung
ihrer Bezüge einstellen nach offizieller
Schätzung sollen die Renten im Juli in
Westdeutschland laut deutscher
Presseagentur um 5,2% steigen im Osten
um 5,9 in diesem Jahr gab es wegen
Corona im Westen eine Nullrunde im Osten
ein leichtes Plus
bei den Tarifgesprächen im öffentlichen
Dienst der Länder stockt es die
Gewerkschaften kündigten jetzt nach der
zweiten Verhandlungsrunde an die
Warnstreiks deutlich auszuweiten
Schwerpunkt soll das Gesundheitswesen
sein Verdi und der Beamtenbund fordern
für die etwa 1,1 Millionen Angestellten
5% mindestens jedoch 150 Euro mehr
Einkommen die Arbeitgeber haben noch
kein Angebot vorgelegt
weniger Ausstoß des klimaschädlichen
Gases Methan und mehr Schutz für die
Wälder dieses Signal kommt heute von der
Weltklimakonferenz in Glasgow soll bis
2030 die Zerstörung von Wäldern gestoppt
werden mehr als 100 Länder beteiligen
sich an dieser Initiative bei ihnen
wachsen mehr als 85% des globalen
Baumbestandes auch Brasilien und
Russland sind dabei und ebenfalls mehr
als 100 Länder haben sich verpflichtet
im gleichen Zeitraum den Methanausstoß
um mindestens 30% zu reduzieren Volker
Angriff
McKenzies Miss jagt das Klimagas Methan
Sensoren fangen das Gas auf die
Wissenschaftlerin fliegt im Auftrag
großer Energiefirmen
sie versuchen richtig große Lex zu
entdecken und wenn wir für einen
Betreiber unterwegs sind alarmieren wir
ihn damit Sie schnellstmöglich stopfen
kann
unterwegs ist sie im texanischen Odessa
dem größten Fördergebiet für Öl und Gas
in den USA die Werte sind alarmierend
fast 4% Methan entweichen in die
Atmosphäre
Sibirien auch hier entweicht Methan
kommt aus dem Permafrostboden Pflanzen
die sich zersetzen
methan ist ein Klimawandel Turbo wirkt
rund 20 Mal stärker als CO2 30% weniger
Methanemissionen bis 2030 das
versprachen heute in Glasgow mehr als
100 Staaten und noch ein Versprechen
heute 114 Staaten geben zusammen 12
Milliarden US-Dollar um die Zerstörung
der Wälder bis 2030 zu stoppen in
einigen Ländern wie zum Beispiel in
Brasilien aber auch in Teilen Afrikas
sind die Emissionen aus Entwaldung also
aus Zerstörung von Wäldern mit die
größten Emissionen überhaupt das heißt
wir müssen die Industrie Emissionen auf
der einen Seite senken wir müssen Wälder
aber auch Moore zum Beispiel erhalten
Glasgow entwickelt sich zur Konferenz
der schnellen Projekte wohlgemerkt neben
der eigentlichen Aufgabe das
Klimaschutzabkommen von Paris
abzuarbeiten Umweltverbände aber bleiben
skeptisch denn was am Ende zählt ist die
konkrete Umsetzung vielleicht geht es ja
so moderne Aufforstung per Drohne 7000
Samen pro Stunde ein Mensch bräuchte
dafür sechs Tage
in afghanischen Hauptstadt Kabul sind
beim Angriff auf ein Militärkrankenhaus
mindestens zwölf Menschen getötet worden
so ein Sprecher der regierenden
radikalislamischen Taliban nach einer
Explosion am Eingang der Klinik kam es
auf dem Gelände offenbar zu
Schusswechseln zwischen Angreifern und
Sicherheitskräften seit der
Machtübernahme der Taliban im August gab
es mehrere Anschläge durch Ableger des
sogenannten islamischen Staates
es war auch ein Anhänger des is der vor
genau einem Jahr mitten in Wien mehrere
Menschen tötete heute erinnert die Stadt
mit Gedenkfeiern an die Opfer am 2
November 2020 hatte der 20-Jährige in
einem Ausgehviertel der österreichischen
Hauptstadt um sich geschossen vier
Passanten starben darunter auch eine
24-jährige Deutsche Studentin mehr als
20 Menschen wurden verletzt der
Angreifer wurde durch Schüsse der
Polizei getötet
haben sie auch wie viele schon mal im
Internet ein Elektrogerät zu einem
Schnäppchenpreis gekauft das Problem
viele dieser Geräte sind gefährlich das
reicht von Rauchmelder der keinen Rauch
meldet bis zum Babyspielzeug mit
giftigen Inhaltsstoffen die Geräte
entsprechen nicht den
Sicherheitsstandards und dürften gar
nicht angeboten werden wie sie trotzdem
im Netz landen zeigt Ihnen Eleni
klozykas
dieser Föhn der markeplus Soleil darf
nicht mehr verkauft werden wer ihn
benutzt kann einen elektrischen Schlag
bekommen deshalb ist der auf safety-gate
gelistet einer EU-Datenbank mit
gefährlichem Produkten die vom Markt
genommen wurden bei Amazon entdecken wir
einen Föhn der dem verbotenen sehr
ähnlich sieht nur mit einem anderen
Markennamen und auch dieser Föhn ist bei
safety-gate gelistet und auch er taucht
bei Amazon unter anderem Namen auf das
hat System beklagen Verbraucherschützer
so was heutzutage eigentlich passiert
ist dass es Meldungen gibt an den
Online-Marktplatz hier mit dem Produkt
XYZ ist irgendwas nicht in Ordnung und
dann wird das auch runter genommen und
was dann passiert ist dass die der
Händler der möglicherweise in China
sitzt und dem sein Produkt jetzt nicht
mehr verfügbar ist einfach einen neuen
Namen einen neuen Shop kreiert und das
gleiche Produkt eigentlich dann zwei
Tage später wieder neu anbietet
Labortests bestätigen die Haartrockner
weisen die gleichen Risiken auf wie die
bereits verbotenen Amazon teilt mit
Sicherheit habe oberste Priorität und
hat die Produkte vorläufig vom Markt
genommen 6 europäische
Verbraucherorganisationen haben bei
verschiedenen Shoppingportalen Produkte
bestellt und getestet die Untersuchungen
zeigen ein Großteil hatte
Sicherheitsmängel
viel Verbraucher kommen diese Produkte
wirklich teilweise mit tödlichen
Gefahren daher wir haben in manchen
Produktgruppen nicht ein einziges
legales Produkt gefunden
verbraucherschützer fordern deshalb
schärfere Regeln die neue
Bundesregierung müsse sich bei der
EU-Kommission dafür stark machen dass
Online-Marktplätze für die Produkte mit
haften
und mehr zu gefährlichen Elektrogeräten
im Onlinehandel in frontal heute Abend
um 9 Uhr
der Countdown für Astronaut Matthias
Maurer läuft aber wohl noch ein bisschen
länger als geplant sein Staat zur
Internationalen Raumstation verschiebt
sich zum zweiten Mal erst spielte das
Wetter nicht mit nun ist ein Q Mitglied
erkrankt stand jetzt soll es Sonntag
Nacht um 4:36 Uhr deutscher Zeit endlich
losgehen von Cape Canaveral zur ISS dann
wäre Maurer der 12 deutsche mal
zurück zur Erde zur Fußball Champions
League Norbert und zu den Bayern ja die
müssen heute Abend gegen Benfica
Lissabon ran wieder auf der Bank darüber
Standard corona-infektion Münchens
Trainer Julian nagelsmann und der will
mit dem vierten Sieg im vierten Spiel
vorzeitig ins Achtelfinale einziehen
heute Mittag beim ausschwitzen an der
selbener Straße geriet das Spiel gegen
Benfica Lissabon fast zur Nebensache
ich fühle mich gut natürlich merkt man
immer noch dass irgendwas im Körper war
ich glaube es ist auch normal das zeigen
auch die Studien aber ich habe jetzt
habe keine keine Dinge mehr die mich
hemmen ich bin gut drauf Joshua Kimmich
dürfte erleichtert sein dass das
Medieninteresse nun wieder der
bayerischen Spielfreude gilt wie beim
5:2 gegen Union Berlin allerdings gab es
in der Münchner Abwehr erneut schwere
Stellungsfehler die auch am Samstag
wieder zwei Gegentore zuließen doch
solange sich das Team auf seine
brillante Offensive verlassen kann sind
große Sprünge auch heute gegen Lissabon
wieder möglich
FIFA-Präsident Josef Blatter und exoefa
Boss Michelle Platini müssen in der
Schweiz vor Gericht die Anklage wirft
ihnen Betrug vor es geht um eine
angeblich unrechtmäßige Zahlung von 2
Millionen Franken von Blatter am
plantini
tenniskrimi zum Auftakt des letzten
Masters Turniers der Saison Paris nach
drei Stunden besiegt Dominik Köpfer den
widerstarken zweimaligen
Wimbledon-Gewinner Andy Murray nach
Abwehr von sieben Matchbällen
Dominik Köpfer nach seinem bislang
emotionalsten sie und eine Match das
weder die Zuschauer noch der ehemalige
Weltrang des erste Murray vergessen
werden der einstige collegespieler
Köpfer führt nach spektakulären Schlägen
wie diesem bereits mit 6:44 zu 3 doch
wenn Andy Murray für eine Eigenschaft
berühmt ist dann dafür niemals
aufzugeben unfassbar wie gut er mit
künstlicher Hüfte wieder mitmischt in
der Weltklasse
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dreht die Partie und der kämpft sich
insgesamt sieben Matchbälle Köpfer
jedoch wird alle sieben mit eisernen
Nerven ab exemplarisch hier der vierte
Dominik Köpfer genügt dann ein einziger
Matchball zum Sieg bei 10:9 Führung im
Tie-Break des dritten Satzes ein
denkwürdiger Abend für den 27-Jährigen
der damit wieder die Top 50 der Welt
ansteuert
und Köpfer trifft er morgen in der
zweiten Runde auf den Kanadier verließ
Sushi Alina
zum Wetter neuer Regen kommt aber auch
Sonnenschein ist dabei mehr dazu gleich
von özdentelli Klaus Kleber hat das
heute journal für Sie um 21.45 machen
sie es gut
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter von Frankreich her
erreichte uns das nächste Tief und das
bringt schon in der zweiten Nachthälfte
von Südwesten her erregen und auch im
Tagesverlauf ist eine Menge Regen im
Südwesten dabei schauen wir uns die
Nachtkarte an und da gibt es in der
Mitte und nach Nordwesten hin Regen der
wird allmählich weniger in der Nacht
aber von Südwesten her erreicht uns
neuer Regen ansonsten nach nordenden
lockert es auf teilweise bildet sich
Nebel die tiefsten Temperaturen an den
Alpen mit -1° hier also leichter Frost
sechs Grad am Oberrhein und auch an der
Nordsee häufig Werte um die 5 Grad Marke
also ein recht kalte Nacht
morgen einen Tagesverlauf im Südwesten
die dichten Wolken und Regen kann auch
mal kräftiger sein nach Osten denn ist
es freundlicher genauso wie in Bayern
und an der Nordsee bei höchsten
Temperaturen von sechs Grad in der Eifel
und 12 Grad im Osten Deutschlands die
nächsten Tage am Donnerstag sehr
durchwachsen mit teils ergiebigen Regen
der nordwärts zieht Schneefallgrenze bei
800 Meter an den Alpen fünf bis zehn
Grad die höchsten Werte und die
darauffolgenden Tage nicht mehr ganz so
nass aber ähnlich kühl ein schöner Abend